in just a moment we will present
Hollywood's top glamour event of the
year the 30 second star-studded Academy
Awards presentation immediately
following the award see the Jack Paar
show over most of these NBC stations its
Oscar night in Hollywood this is the
Pantages Theatre where the elite the
motion picture industry and the
entertainment press of the world
gathered for the 32nd annual Achievement
Awards of the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences this evenings
excitement begins with the overture a
medley of songs by one of the Academy's
most nominated composers Harold Arlen
the Academy Award Orchestra Andre Previn
conducting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. beebe Kahane
[Music]
[Applause]
members of the Academy ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome to
the 32nd annual Academy Awards
presentation the Academy is again
graceful is grateful to the producers
distributors the artists and all other
segments of the industry who have made
it possible for us to bring this program
to you as a public service why are these
awards so important at least to us I
think it is because they represent the
judgment of our co-workers our peers
they decide which of us has done
something about standing merit
nearly 2200 members of the Academy have
voted and tonight we will hear their
winners the pictures of this year have
been rich and varied they have been
rewarding experiences for all of us and
it seems that it is only proper that the
people who made these pictures should
also be rewarded in some fashion and
that is what we propose to do tonight
now to begin the countdown to sudden
glory here is a gentleman who has become
a permanent member of our annual program
the distinguished representative of
Price Waterhouse and company mr. bill
Miller
as you know mr. Miller is the zealous
guardian of the sealed envelopes that
contain the winners names mr. Cain I
would like to present you with your
certification in Price Waterhouse has
again supervised the mailing of the
ballots and has tabulated the results
which I have here in the sealed envelope
thank you now for the first category the
selection of a master of ceremonies for
the evening this is a role that calls
for charm and grace and whipped and the
nominees are Bob Hope for whipped Robert
hope for grace and Leslie towns hope for
child the special envelope mr. Miller
the winner mr. Bob Hope
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
Thank You president Kahane and how do
you do ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to Hollywood's most glamorous strike
meeting
now this is if our annual show welcome
to the moment of truth
by the way I'm Bob Hope known as the
trade as better luck next year always an
usher that's the way I am always an
usher never than never an Anthony
Armstrong Jones
ladies and gentlemen we have a wonderful
audience here tonight a glamorous
audience mink furs jewels
looks like the basement of the Chicago
Police Station
and I've been asked to make an
announcement before we go ahead mr.
William Wyler will you please see the
cop out front
your chariot is double-parked many
changes have been made since our last
show we have a new producer a new
director and a new watch
personally tested by John Cameron Swayze
gathered here tonight of the first
mink-lined pickets in history I never
thought I'd live to see the day when
Ronald Regan was the only actor working
even the publicity men are out there
hasn't been a single jewel robbery
during the sprites right but the strike
is right there
I'm alright I'll be fine about an hour
now both factions in the striker here
tonight and I want to say the best
acting performance is the year going on
right in the audience
just shows you what kind of people
actors are who else would give up
working for Lent
and I want to tell you the actors
assured anybody that's still working one
guy was carrying a sign Mickey Mouse is
a Fink I'm personally not interested in
more money for my movies on television
I'm striking for police protection now
it's a nasty mess though actors strike
against producers producers bitter
against writers agents starving in the
streets was this the kind of world you
wanted Elvis to come home to in spite of
it all it's a wonderful country isn't it
where else can a man walk off a job and
refuse to get out of his swimming pool
unless they improve working conditions
and I want to tell you there's a lot of
pictures only half shot one Western
pictures hung up and it's quite a
situation there's a hundred and fifty
Indians crouched behind a boulder at
Corrigan Ville and no one's told them
John Wayne isn't coming but I must say
that the strike has been very peaceful
outside of a couple of nasty incidents
sir Cedric Hardwicke pushed Jack Warner
into the popcorn machine and someone
poured weed killer on Hedda hoppers hat
but I must say the actors treated us I
the producers treated us actors with
tact and reasonableness at the last
meeting they brought in their own
unbiased mediator Fidel Castro but this
is a great night and in spite of the
strike this is the night when all film
land gathers to honor its fellow
craftsmen before urgent and take up a
new line of work and you can just feel
the tension in this theater there's so
much much electricity in the air anyone
wearing a Dacron suit is helpless for
many there will be heartbreaking tears
others fame and fortunately I can go
anyway
I've taken a tons of mill town and the
life-insurance policy incidentally
there'd be no commercials on this show
I'm sorry I'm sorry
you should have thought of it before you
sat down but anyway we have our show is
is being telecast on the full NBC
network and will be shown overseas to
our Armed Forces Armed Forces providing
general Jimmy Stewart wins
if not it'll be buried with the first
missile leaving Cape Canaveral Jimmy
Stewart was great I thought in that
picture it's people like him who keep
people in theaters and me from Oscar's
in anatomy of a murder was wonderful how
he won the case for that fellow I know
someone who's seen the picture 15 times
dr. Finch
when the nominations were first
announced my wife got a big thrill and
she found out it was a different lemon
now Jack Lemmon was nominated for
impersonating a girl I remember when he
used to get arrested for that
which reminds me in England Charley's
aunt finally made it Jack lemon is the
first camp totally an hour and a half
don't fool with it you might a jack
lemmon is the first comedian ever
nominated for the best actor award and
it gives me something to shoot at my
agent for instance and Charlton Heston
getting an award for been hurt how do
you figure it the most coveted award in
the world of entertainment for a drag
race our big pictures this year have had
some intriguing themes sex persecution
adultery and cannibalism we'll get those
kids away from their TV sets yet
the only thing produced with this year
with the seal was a Walt Disney short
but the industry can take great pride in
its achievement this year it's the first
time we've had smelly's on purpose
pictures that smell isn't that wonderful
I remember when you have to wait for the
reviews on the beach was great that was
premiered Moscow the Russians loved it
they thought it was a newsreel
this was the year Marlon Brando became
the director of a Western it's the first
picture ever made with method horses
pretty soon there would be nothing but
offbeat psychological adult westerns
tomorrow when a hero gets shot by the
villain he says I wonder what he meant
by that
I have my own personal selections for
awards this year the best achievement in
sound spire scores having lunch with
Khrushchev
the best in short subjects Bing Crosby
couldn't forget dead best dramatic
performance of the year Jack Park but
let's have Price Waterhouse get on with
the awards we know these rewards are
absolutely honest and aboveboard because
in 32 years
neither price nor Waterhouse has ever
won an Oscar and I can vouch for their
honesty believe me if they never take a
bribe I'd be the first to know
but enough of bitterness let's get on to
open hatred
to present the first Oscar for the best
documentary films of 1959 a talented
young lady I've known since she was a
child star back in the good old days
when agents used to be barred from the
studio's they now own the lovely miss
Mitzi Gaynor right here
[Music]
roughly speaking a documentary film is a
nonfiction motion picture only those
made that way on purpose are eligible
for this award the nominees for the best
documentary feature are the race for
space David L wolf / producer Serengeti
shall not die
Bernard rhythmic producer and the winner
is Serengeti shall not die Bernard
rhythmic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I thank the American Film Academy for
the great honour to evolve meets his
famous Oscar prize and to the people who
have focused public interest in our work
in this country that equally mister
volgas oh I think you're not in my name
I am only co-producer of this film but
in the name of my late friend and son
Michael who has been killed just when
finishing as much work in Africa and his
film he should spend this evening
on night race thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for the best documentary
short subjects are Donald in mathmagic
land Walt Disney producer from
generation to generation Edward F Cullen
producer and glass Burt monstre producer
and the winner is glass bird hunter
producer myth and lights will accept the
award for Miss Hofstra
gee I guess this is the closest I'll
ever get to one I would like to say on
behalf of mr. Han Stroh how happy I'm
sure he used and thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing left over